you lived in New York City you get
through New York City and now you've
moved to Los Angeles you made the big
move are you adjusting do you like los
like la I Love New York I Love New York
I was just there last week and renewed
my love for it all the walking around
here it's all about driving you know LA
car culture I work in an office in
Hollywood and park on the street go into
my office this is a couple weeks ago
come back out a couple of hours later
car gone really gone but on the little
meter sign there is a temporary towaway
thing right so I'm like oh I must have
screwed up maybe I didn't see that sign
I'm stupid I called it a number for the
tow thing and I'm here at my car here's
where it was that and I'm they go we
don't have it
your car's been stolen and I was like
that can't be right but okay they're
like you need to go to the police
station right now
and report it stolen this is where it is
for that thing so I walked to the police
station
and I'm like doopa doopa doopa hi my car
was still in the middle in the middle of
the day and they were like really and I
was like yeah so I fill out a whole
police report I'm there for a very long
time how long like I'm there a couple of
hours and they go through the whole
thing with me i watch a number of insane
things transact in the lobby of the
police station and as we're wrapping up
the guy goes so helpful so lovely he's
like hands me other thing he's like this
is for you you might want to go back to
where you parked it and walk around a
little and I was like why he was like
some people don't always remember where
they parked was like okay so I walk back
I go and I start doing cert wider
circles around where I parked cars four
blocks from where I was sitting there
like perfectly see and I was like oh no
no I'm like here's my car the relief of
I have meanwhile I've called my parents
to tell them my car is stolen I'm
supposed to be doing a comedy show it's
now nighttime I cancelled it told the
whole cast of the comedy show can't make
it tonight guys my car has been still
but told all my friends now I have found
my car exactly where I parked I have to
report locks we're not I mean not
scooted by four blocks even four block
it's legit embarrassing I have to call
it in to the police because the end
they're gonna go don't get in that car
stolen car I go don't get in that car
because we're out right now our cars are
looking for it actively and you will be
held at gunpoint as the thinking and I
was like you have no idea you don't know
what I look like
yeah people are already suspicious that
I just pick the face when they pull up
to you this is my car
[Applause]